more than 10 years after going off the
air suppose show is still eminently
watchable quotable and hilarious but why
did Dave Chappelle resonate in the first
place and why after all these years do
we still need him more than ever
high and low has anybody so enthusiastic
about diarrhea humor ever been called a
genius as often as Dave Chappelle in a
single stand-up set he can go from mud
butt into dangerous neighborhoods
highlight the injustice of our legal
system incisively criticized the
president and then leaves the planet
with three clone triplets a space alien
and the cure for AIDS you almost don't
realize you're learning something he
shows his flaws the hardest part of
being relatable is letting yourself be a
little vulnerable Chappelle is a master
of reminding us that he's just another
guy while be successful but just as
insecure as anybody else and he's not
afraid to admit when he's made a mistake
or at least a bad joke the infamous
Wayne Brady incident is a perfect
example what's a joke about Brady's
supposed whiteness going too far
white people love Wayne Brady because he
makes Brian Gumbel look like Malcolm X
Chappelle brought Brady on the show as
an apology the resulting sketch about
how Brady was to Street eating first
Chappelle became an instant classic and
all because Chappelle was open enough to
realize and apologize for his mistake
hip hop ambassador the show's
relationship with music brought some of
the all-time greats into homes of
millions of Americans
but it's the movie Dave Chappelle's
block party that really proves his
hip-hop and soul bona fides the movie is
a behind-the-scenes look at the days
leading up to a free block party Dave
they're on the streets of New York
it's inclusiveness is heartwarming and
joy radiates from every frame next thing
we know
Dave Chappelle do you like rap music
where y'all come to my block party Neil
it's in Brooklyn on Saturday it's the
rare concert film that feels truly
special as the show goes on in the
pouring rain in front of an audience
full of people who otherwise might not
be able to afford the concerts fantastic
lineup oh and there's some jokes too
master of the craft Dave famously got a
start and stand-up at a young age
climbing onstage at 14 and just ripping
on whatever sure he has is constructed
jokes but he's comfortable fitting them
in between bits of
stream-of-consciousness comedy and
audience interaction sometimes it
backfires and his comedy turns downright
antagonistic but even when it's not
funny
there's something thrilling about seeing
a master in the process of creating
frank an inclusive on brace if there's
one thing about Chappelle's comedy that
has true importance it's the Frank way
in which he talks about race using humor
to bridge the gaps between people take
for example the classic sketch I know
black people in which Chappelle
irreverently explores the inherent humor
in our differences by testing random
people on their knowledge of black
culture it's these little observations
surfaced funny but deeply felt that
truly you a service to society at large
we're different but we're not that
different and none of us are too good to
be the butt of a great joke it's an
approach that brings us closer and it's
why even all these years after he ends
out of the spotlight we're still waiting
for Dave Chappelle thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what your favorite Dave Chappelle
sketches